this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
army's museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history and on this week's episode he's
taking a look at more of escape from
tarkov's weapons
including some horrifically cursed ones
oh my god for the love of god
if you want to see more of jonathan
reacting to escape from tarkov make sure
to subscribe and check out the previous
videos we made on the game's extensive
arsenal
and if you'd like to help out the royal
army's museum and continue to support
jonathan's work
check out the links in the description
of this video right
over to jonathan
people have on and off been a bit
obsessed with hybridizing
the ak and the ar15 family of rifles
i suppose because they are the top two
so i think there's a bit of a
fascination with smashing those two
designs together
and the obvious idea is you get all of
the ergonomic benefits
certainly to a western military user of
an ar
with the caliber or cartridge type of
the ak now whether that's really an
advantage or not depends who you talk to
we haven't got one to compare it to but
it looks to be well implemented got some
nice
those lovely meaty sound effects and
um all of the right handling animations
press check after loading all that kind
of stuff all looking good
of all the games to feature a hybrid ar
ak
tarkov seems like the one with the most
merit
oh really gonna have to pause there
right well i've had to pause there just
because of the unloading animation i
suppose i'd call it
which you might have seen in uh in some
films some tv shows
uh it always brings to mind for me man
on fire with denzel washington
where he's going through this ritual of
this lucky or unlucky round
but uh he'll take the magazine out and
pull back the slide
just the right angle on his glock to be
able to catch the ejected round and it's
sort of a
ritual that he goes through to unload
his pistol in that way i've seen a few
other people do it this way as well
quite a few competition shooters i don't
think you'll see that in a military
context but then
what's the origin of the player here
don't know so the way it's where it
should work
of course is you have to remove the
ammunition source from the gun
to leave only the round in the chamber
because otherwise
when you pull the slide back sharply to
release the round to catch it it'll just
chamber the next one and all you're
doing is removing one round from your
magazine
it's a flamboyant way to unload your
pistol essentially
slightly curious clip there where we've
loaded into the game
and appears to be one round in the gun
so around in the chamber none in the
magazine
first shot goes off then there's a click
but the slide hasn't locked open
the only way that would happen in real
life is if you um limp wristed the gun
and there wasn't enough resistance for
the slider cycle and
or there was a malfunction with the
weapon and one way or another the slide
didn't lock open
because the slide should lock open so
yeah we're interesting
uh anomaly there p if you if you know
what happened there and whether it's a
quirk of the game or i'm missing
something please do
let me know
can i just say how nice it is to see a
single pistol round
actually killing somebody in a game not
that common if you think about it
normally pistols are an entry level
weapon and they are
usually nerfed effectively in in power
in penetration or damage or whichever
stat
is is the operative one you know that's
sort of the case pistol rounds are a lot
less powerful than rifle rounds but
a pistol bullet will still seriously
ruin your day
now we know armor is a big thing in in
tarkov so obviously if a pistol round
struck armor we would expect you to be
able to
walk that off but if you if you hit
anything vital
one shot's enough so i think tarkov gets
that about right from what i've seen
right this time i actually glimpsed on
the screen
a warning of a malfunction specifically
misfire
so that means that the firing pin has
struck the primer on the cartridge and
the cartridge has failed to ignite
bad ammunition bad primer whatever and
so you'd have to clear that malfunction
the typical default for that would be to
smack the magazine to make sure it's
seated and cycle the gun
to eject the failed round or whatever
the stoppage might be that that is
designed to account for a number of
eventualities but in this case that
would certainly work
because it would get your dud round out
of the gun and the next one into the
chamber
yeah so this is this is a deliberate
effort to break my
might break my brain isn't it well
um they wanted a reaction and um
here it is it's it's a firearm that only
a mother could love i think he's
probably the best thing i can say about
it so it's our old friend the
the mosin or the mosin nagant or the
three-line rifle
and it has been butchered there's some
sort of muzzle device on it that i can't
quite see
thank thankfully uh scope mount with a
with a
20 power scope or something on it a
light and laser module
i i suppose you could you could maybe
live with that but then we have a sawn
off
grip sticking out the back of the gun
wrapped in blue electrical tape i think
that is
and then the final kind of kick in the
nuts really
is the uh ergonomic pistol grip which is
a contradiction in terms when you're
dealing with this thing
which is just a complete stranger to the
concept of ergonomics
this has been done deliberately and uh
it hasn't gone unnoticed
right so i hadn't noticed the laser on
the other side so we've got two lasers
i think this thing would have a modicum
of merit if you ditch the scope
because it's clearly even in the game i
think it's easier to use
with the lasers than with the scope and
just try and sort of
hip fire the thing which lasers are you
know that's what lasers are for
not necessarily hip firing but um aiming
using the laser
beam rather than the sight they have
their place but i'm not sure their place
is strapped to the size of a mosin the
gowns
so you're not i was not at all surprised
to see the sks crop up in
tarkov there would be lots of these
potentially floating around
as the once briefly primary
infantry rifle of the soviet army good
job
of modeling it i think the i was thrown
at first by the detachable
magazine both variants we saw there were
fitted with the detachable magazine with
a funny little
little well very long front attachment
lug
i actually had to look this up i was not
familiar with these aftermarket
extended round extended capacity
magazines needless to say
being the game that it is they are a
real thing now i've grabbed this one
um not because not just to show you an
sks they're 10 a penny this came back
from iraq and it has been chromed all of
the metal work on this despite the
the rough appearance overall
it does look a little sorry for itself
but it has literally been in the wars
so this is a russian 1952 example
from iraqi service chromed for parade
use of some kind it's now a historical
artifact
and then the other variant we saw was
the dreaded
tapco sks which we've seen in
battlefield as well
nothing against tapco's company they
offer
aftermarket furniture and accessory
upgrades for
legacy rifles like like this so if you
want
your rifle to look more modern and be a
bit more a bit more ergonomic
you can upgrade your rifle in that way
traditionalists like like me
rifle is fine
the mdr as you can this is the desert
tech mdr
micro dynamic rifle quite a few eyes
have been on this thing
lately in firearms world because it's a
sort of
brand new design of the last five ten
years and is
we're sort of watching its development
in real time as it becomes more and more
effective
so that was a really good example of
sound design and
trying to try to represent what happens
when you take a firearm
from outdoors indoors and what happens
in reality is unless you've got hearing
protection on
you get death because even a pistol let
alone a rifle
the the concussion the blast it's it's
pretty over
overpowering uh but you can you can
readily tell the difference in the game
as you should be able to between
how resonant how loud apparently loud
the sound
is there's a simple function of sound
waves bouncing off walls and ceilings
and floors
whereas outdoors of course it's just the
floor and anything that
is nearby it's happening again
just pause
oh god i don't know where to start
somehow this is worse
so we've got wooden furniture on an ar
which is
you know you can get that i don't know i
think the the the gigantic coffin mag
kind of tips it over the edge into
insanity the giant scope
essentially preventing you from cocking
it properly although the
player manages it fine but then they've
removed the stock
entirely leaving just the buffer tube so
you can't shoulder this thing
a short barrel as well so it's not even
like an svd length barrel
and then just to top it off we've got
like the surefire 100 round
magazine it's a masterpiece well and
here we see the result
uh probably similar to the result
we'd observe in real life of removing
the buttstock from
an ar-15 and firing it on automatic
because it
climbs to the heavens made all the more
exaggerated by the
view through the scope that we're
getting it's making a statement
and i think that statement is i have no
idea how guns should
be
right so this is something i i did see
this this was
caused a mild stir in the gun world a
few weeks ago
a heavily tricked out version of the
baikal
mp 155 baikal being um
part of the kalashnikov group um so the
155 was a
fairly standard shotgun this thing
looked like something straight out of
doom 2016. a feature that i was not
aware of
is this thermal sight screen
built into the top of the gun i'm not
actually convinced that's a real thing
on the mp155 perhaps someone can confirm
one way or the other
um that that um shape of the of the
stock of the furniture
chassis or whatever is part of the
design but uh the version i saw in a
promotional video did not have a camera
in that position
it's a mystery practically speaking as
to why you'd want one firstly on a
on a shotgun well i guess there might be
a need in low light conditions for a
thermal
optic of some sort on a shotgun and then
to have it built in with a display at an
angle that you have to look down at i
mean i guess the idea is threat
identification on the screen and then
you use the sight
but the gun itself is a genuine russian
shotgun
so why wouldn't you put it in escape
from tarkov
so apparently gestures are a thing in
this game and that
player decided to flip off our our hero
as he gunned him down i don't know if he
knew him or if he just realized that he
couldn't
win that gunfight and decided to go down
flipping him off
either way pretty hilarious
oh my god
for the love of god just when i think
we're going back to normal and i'm
prepared because i know that this this
weapon
was actually procured with a forward
rail system and a suppressor mount so i
was i was ready for
an unconventional looking pistol and we
have
what looked like a pair of gigantic
flashlights
mounted to the the side rails which you
could do you could absolutely do with
this pistol i've got a red dot sight on
the top absolutely fine suppressor yes
it's designed for suppression
it's just the the fog lamps that
don't really make any sense so as soon
as these flashlights get turned on we
lose our optical sight entirely and
essentially
the player is using the white disc that
appears
of light that appears in the optic as
their way of aiming i imagine
and of course from the um from the
victim's point of view
similar to real life you are going to be
um unable to function or at least unable
to see
where to return fire so but again you
can achieve that effect with a single
small flashlight rather than three giant
ones
right a um increasingly iconic russian
firearm the ash 12
and you get a really good view of really
the whole design purpose of this when
the player takes the magazine off and
looks at the rounds they look like a
northern felt
manually operated machine gun round
they're just immense
a 55 millimeter long case so it's not a
12.7 by 108 dushka round but you're
still getting hit by
something of significant weight and
diameter
with a lot more power behind it than a
desert eagle 50 caliber round
and now the implications within tarkov
much like in the real world
is where you're gonna get your ammo from
if you're not being supplied by
the russian military supply train um you
can't make it from anything else
you're not gonna find it lying around
farmers and their mums
are not going to be uh concealing this
in a barn or something
so uh full automatic with this thing
indoor in a corridor is
i mean i don't have headphones on or
anything but i can imagine what that
sounds like and
um if you're the poor sap that gets
opened up on by this thing in those
confined quarters i imagine there's
going to be some um a bit of a bit of a
pucker factor
as they say in the u.s military
all right i'm feeling less left out now
because we do have
several statchens in the collection here
at the royal armouries
and the apb is one of them so this is
the suppressed
variant that we see in that clip
complete with wire
shoulder stock which is detachable with
a latch
underneath and then uh
the suppressor is actually stored
on the wire buttstock which is really
quite impressive quite a long suppressor
with a lot of volume for the cartridge
type
so should be pretty effective i haven't
heard one of these fired so i don't know
how realistic the
suppressed sound effect in the game was
but it sounded about right to me
right this one i actually had to look up
it rang a bell but i couldn't recall
what it was and it's another
russian design that i sadly haven't got
my hands
on lebayev i hope that's vaguely the
right
pronunciation and it's the dvl series
specifically this one is the saboteur
this is
a real product in their range of course
it is it's tarkov
so we've seen some scope adjustment
there so we've got we've got a giant
long range scope on this thing with a
little comedy red dot
sight piggy backing on the top for close
range what we saw there was the
player adjusting the people it's often
referred to as zeroing technically
zeroing is making your point of aim
point of impact
coincide at a certain distance
in other words both up and down and left
and right in video games when we say
zeroing what we really mean is
elevation adjustment or bullet drop
compensation and you can see the reticle
actually move
and the player scores a head shot and i
think i saw 200 flash ups i'm guessing
that's 200 meters
oh
pause okay this is getting ridiculous
now
i i actually am lost for words at that
one i think it's the just
juxtaposition of no top cover and a
whacking great picatinny rail sight
mount
almost acting as a top cover i think
that's just giving me an aneurysm
and then the the stacked sights attached
to the scope
what can i say it's it's just a
masterpiece and i am
speechless oh oh i spoke too soon
i spoke too soon because now we have a
drum magazine
merrily clipping through our wrist which
i think just goes to show that even the
game doesn't approve of this
you see they've brought they brought
this upon themselves by giving you
functionality well a to let you build
something like this and
b to be able to toggle through your
different optics which i'm pretty sure
is designed for
a piggyback red dot or a canted reflex
sight
not three red dots mounted to the top of
your scope
all of which are functional i don't know
whether to be impressed or disgusted i
genuinely don't
well thanks for watching my final
descent into madness
guys uh quite the series we've built up
now of um
tarkov reaction so do go back and watch
the earlier more sane
ones if you'd like to if you'd like to
support the work we do at the royal
armouries as ever we have links in the
description
please come and visit us if you're able
to do so and we have got our own
youtube channel where every week i do a
short video
on something interesting from the stores
so join us if you can
otherwise thank you very much for
watching i'll see you next time
[Music]
you